[Music]
in friends poor health and news
submitted by your northern neighbors
spending time with friends is one of the
best things you can do for your health I
agree
unless your friends are toxic they need
you to run away yeah mental health Oh No
physical health to physical health yep
so if I got a clue oh I mean I got a
cold if I got a cold is it cold
you haven't got a clue it was a cold in
a flutist Rima yeah if I got a clue I
wanted to say both and it both came out
yeah you did it all right so this there
this article years are talking about how
like the complete opposite of spending
time with your friends would be social
isolation and that is linked to higher
rates of chronic diseases and mental
health conditions and it may even
catalyze cellular level changes that
promote chronic inflammation and
suppress community so it actually has
physical effects to your body if you are
socially isolated but what if all my
friends have the clue and then they get
me sick that's really a question true
yep you don't want the clothes no but
you'll have higher immunity though oh so
I'll get it and then we'll all get it
together I put them we'll get rid of it
well you won't even get it cuz your
immunity is higher so you're afraid
we're trying to pass the clue on what if
you're an introvert and social
situations stress you out
that's me dude see I know that's my wife
yes so they're saying like you know
throughout a long period of time if you
have social anxiety and stuff and if you
are removing yourself from social
situations because of that anxiety you
will have health problems it probably
depends on each person's amount that
they need to feel whole so like
introverts maybe they need like some
good quality time with one or two of
their really close friends and then cuz
you're still socializing right but then
extroverts probably need like novelty
and something different with a lot of
people or whatever so it's just you just
got to get out the damn house is what
they're saying
and laugh with people face-to-face cuz
like me and Joe it recharges us to be
around people but then like Gaelic geo
or Nicky it's like it it's so true yeah
you get tired not tired just like I get
like tired of speaking and just like a
VidCon or something kind of change that
would like two days after I can't be
around long yeah when people are stupid
that's tired but sometimes I like it
because it turns there's a level of like
they're so stupid that it's funny
hmm and then there's like so low like
you guys are like like the dirt of the
earth that I love being here because
it's such good material oh that's an
extrovert as [ __ ] but it yeah it doesn't
bother me right well then like there is
that boredom level of like all these
people are not stimulating to be around
because all they do is like drink and
talk about the same [ __ ] every week yeah
I don't think we hang out with any of
those people cuz it drives me nuts
ya know like this like this morning I
was in line at the gas station and I
watched a man paying $100 for scratchers
tickets but he kept on changing his mind
about which one he was and I could have
waited there all day cuz it was so
fascinating he's like give me the wheel
one and that's like wheel of fortune
give me the wheel one music oh wait hold
on I know you guys had picked pick him
12 oh [ __ ]
and he's like looking at all and reading
the back and [ __ ] and I was like take
your time this is amazing I love that
[ __ ] yeah no oh my god how long do you
think you you three can stay away from
people before you start feeling lonely
Oh am i away from him in your question
yeah like okay I do I really do um
away from him it would be at least a day
but then it most a day I most yeah most
sorry at most a day but then if he's if
he is with me and then all of you guys I
would say maybe a month yeah Oh yours is
longer a night no I I can be I'm fine
without people but I need to see people
like I don't I can't when I lived alone
like I hated it hmm cuz I never had see
anyone and I like do my videos and it's
like I work by myself so I like I need
to see people
at some point during the day I feel like
introverts definitely have a different
experience with people because the way
that you guys get exhausted it's
interesting to me because I see it as
entertainment so I don't internalize or
feel annoyed it actually makes me laugh
but it's options to is not a bad thing
like you can just be like what's it me
and you are hanging out right and i
apprec-- and I appreciate it and I enjoy
our time together um and you don't
necessarily have to be like heavy or bad
but then after I've spent my time with
you like I'm tapped like that's it like
if I don't see anyone else for the rest
of the month I'm like that's okay you
gotta goes just sit on it Carson yeah I
gotta go and like recharge like for me
it's like a workout like you had a
really good workout and then you
expended that energy and now you need to
go rest because it's more the one-on-one
attention that's that's draining for me
even though it's positive but like if
it's a whole group like this um if if I
see conversation it's taking off and I'm
like oh this is tight because now I can
sit back and just listen to that
goodnight it's like well I'm not talking
so my energy is good and I'm just kind
of taking what you guys are saying and
I'm like okay
Kingsley when you lived along are you
like the reason why you felt depressed
is because of isolation let's just the
daily feeling I think so maybe possibly
it was like you don't really have anyone
to talk to or like how your day was or
just to like connect communicate yeah
yeah it is actually like embedded in our
and our DNA that we have to connect with
other people mm-hm we just have to
that's my social isolation leads to so
many health problems because that's not
how we're programmed we're not wired for
that
yeah roommates yeah you don't get mad
why they don't wash the dishes I love
watching dishes oh I do exaggerate dream
zen bro you could be my roommate just
watch have you remote a lawn - I have I
don't have one now so yeah my dad I like
picking up dog [ __ ] yeah
so this Myka just like Daddy
no he goes up trading us it touches it
[Laughter]
oh yeah so they are saying here that
having social support weather comes from
friends family members or your spouse
that it is strongly associated with
better mental health and physical health
so they're saying that study suggests
they can lower stress levels improve
mood encourage positive health behaviors
and discourage damage damaging one it
could also boost cardiovascular health
and improve illness recovery well yeah
people are just like balls of energy too
and in like when you're in a rut and
you're thinking a certain way and
someone else has a different perspective
or energy they can snap you out of that
so regardless of your introvert or
extrovert it doesn't matter because if
you're in a bad place mentally there's
no opportunity for anyone to change your
mind if you're by yourself true yeah but
if you're with a group of people or even
one or two you know that that might see
things differently you might shorten
that span of depression or whatever
because someone gives you a different
way to look at something they just might
be happy and seeing your friend laugh or
you just for a minute you get a break
because you get to laugh about something
together yeah it's definitely true for
me I find it as like not necessarily
like a healing thing for me it's more
like a distraction thing where I'm like
oh I'm feeling like [ __ ] right now but I
get to hang all my friends like you're
distracted from feeling like [ __ ] right
yeah unless if you were at home you
probably feel like [ __ ] from when you
wake up to you go to sleep exactly and
you'll be eating the Apple crying gonna
be washing dishes crying everything
sucks I'll just be in bed crying just
being quiet wake up like if I'm in like
my heavy depression days like I just
want to crawl under the earth and not
surface that's what Nicki does just to
disappear yeah I like to go outside and
laugh at people and come back cuz I feel
better that's good healthy you like I
feel superior to you yeah that's what I
do that's not like
I need you drive away calves like
Chicken Soup for your soul yeah go to
the gym I was about that ass do you guys
actually have to engage with people or
just be around no that's my go today
yeah I'm at the grocery store I'm cool
I see the the-- yeah save me because i'm
not a super big introvert so all I
really need is if just one time a day if
I can get in the presence of people
that's enough and then for me before
it'd be at the gym right just go that I
don't have to talk to people but just
feeling the energy of people or
supermarket or mall or anything or even
if I just get an oil change this I could
just feel the workers and whoever and I
can just go home and I'm good for the
whole day they just recharge me up ready
the biggest surprise to me was finding
out the Gio's introverted and I remember
you actually we had a conversation about
it because because she was like I don't
think cuz I said something about Gio and
then she's like oh no no I don't think
you give me it and then she's like I'm
very introverted and I was like what I
have not been paying attention not all
of them she's actually more introvert
than I am right and I feel like I'm a
big introvert yeah she doesn't have to
say anything about it because she's an
introvert I'm gonna agree yep you got it
what are the like the like what does it
mean it's well if you boil it down
introvert means that you get exhausted
with people or like high stimulation
like situations that are social and it
you need to recharge alone and then
extroverts they thrive where there's a
lot of people and then they charge that
way so it's like introverts need that
space that safe area where they can like
recharge on their own and like relax and
whatever but like I'm an extrovert and I
go crazy because it's not enough
stimulation that up for everything like
you're born an introvert forever or is
it like you got no idea I don't know if
it's learned or what but they've
definitely feel different than when I
was young yeah for sure an extrovert
when I was younger and now I feel more
introverted beaten down by the world
perhaps yeah I think it depends on how
you how you charge so it doesn't mean
that because not all extroverts or party
animals and not all introverts or
homebodies so like like Bart can come
off as an extrovert because he's all
he's out and he's always around people
and I'm always doing something yeah but
in reality that exhausts him and he
needs to charge in the house so it
depends on where you'd like for example
like if you're at home all day you're
you're sad or are you happy cuz if I'm
home all day it drives me insane and I
need to go out and I need to do
something and I need to be around pretty
content all day especially because I got
to see Casey and Isaac summer on them
I'm not completely alone so I don't know
yeah it's all about that were you
charged you know so if you feel a
heightened level of emotion when you're
with people versus being alone then
you're probably an extrovert dude being
around my family and like a big circle
and everyone's just sitting there like
depressed and I'm like there might give
me the [ __ ] out no I'm like this is I
wanna be that in an introvert right now
I want to go somewhere else and just be
alone this feels weird because I feel
like I'm absorbing their [ __ ]
Banerjee into my soul Oh get the [ __ ]
off me no yeah I thought you would laugh
at them only poor people I'm sorry no no
no like not my family I feel sorry for
them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]